over a week since thousands of people
were killed when two dams burst and sent
a wall of water and mud crashing through
the Eastern Libyan city of therna
the search for bodies goes on
many people are still missing and feared
dead many bodies are so decomposed that
identifying them is proving difficult
and disturbing for search and rescue
teams
as a Libyan when I pull out bodies I
swear I cry I can't handle it but it is
God's will so you have to hold up and
pull out the body there was a body that
was cut into two parts right before us
there is nothing to do but to pull out
the bodies what can you do
with so many people unaccounted for and
so many presumed dead the threat of
disease increases by the day
the minister has launched a campaign to
give vaccines for all the categories in
cooperation with the national Center for
Disease Control and the red crescent
some survivors have returned to what
remains of their homes and are overcome
with grief
we found dead bodies of neighbors
friends and loved ones I cannot explain
it
volunteers from across Libya have
crossed the front lines ignoring
violence and political unrest that have
existed for years in this deeply divided
country
many survivors want to know how this
disaster happened and who might be
responsible
I have a small family of six from my
extended family that are more than 48
people missing
God will punish the people who were
supposed to take care of the dam
the UN says that more than 40 000 people
have been forced to flee their homes
it was just like a dream that we can't
comprehend says this man we just can't
comprehend it yet help from abroad
continues to arrive but so far say
International and Libyan officials it's
just not enough
Charles Strafford Al Jazeera
Tamara samadhi is in Darna with the
latest
what we see here is very difficult and
very painful more about this tragedy
that hit derna is being revealed every
day especially in the al-wadi region and
in the al-sahaba neighborhoods these
areas are completely destroyed the
wounded and families of the dead and
injured are describing terrifying
experiences rescue and relief teams are
working around the clock and thousands
of bodies are still in the sea and on
land the challenges are very difficult
for Libyan Arab and international rescue
teams due to the small numbers compared
to the size and scale of Destruction in
the city entire neighborhoods have
completely disappeared as well as roads
buildings and bridges that were swept
towards the Sea by Massive floods Rubble
is everywhere local authorities say the
capabilities are limited and their
equipment and tools are not good enough
to cope with the scale of the disaster
ongoing appeals are being made to
countries around the world to send more
modern equipment and rescue teams
specialize than dealing with such rare
disasters the government emergency
committee has divided the city into
three areas the first is the section
that has been destroyed and people can
no longer live in those who survived
will be evacuated to other places within
days the second area is known as The
Fragile section it was severely damaged
and the houses are no longer suitable
for living in the residents have been
advised to leave the third section is
the least damaged and residents are
being advised to exercise caution and
follow Health instructions especially as
rescue teams have not been able to
recover all the bodies and there are
fears of epidemic spreading local
authorities have sent vehicles to all
areas to spray them with disinfectants
and distribute masks residents have been
warned not to use groundwater and water
from Wells through fear that they may be
contaminated about 40 000 people have
left or have been evacuated from the
city so far and more are expected to do
the same in the coming hours and days